chris is starting off this hour in
Wilmington Delaware welcome to the dive
Ramsey show Chris hi Dave hey what's up
my question is I'm 25 three years out of
college I was extremely lucky to have a
grandfather that paid for my college and
extremely stupid by majoring in
philosophy I want to go back to school
for finance and actually start an actual
career but I don't want to go into debt
I don't have much money to my name and
I'm just wondering what I should do okay
what do you do for a living
I'm a glorified paper scanner okay what
do you make a twenty grand okay working
40 hours yeah cool okay so you want to
study finance where did you graduate
with your undergrad before University of
Delaware okay cool
so have you done any investigation as to
how much of your BA you've been out two
years you said right about three three
okay I'm wondering if some of your
philosophy degree if we can't just make
this a double major and you go back and
like your first two years are probably
out of the way
and you add a couple of years 18 months
of finance classes to it and get a
second major have you investigated any
of that a bit it seems like not a lot
carries over but a bit it would take me
a couple grand a couple of well I'm
talking about years yeah it saved me
about maybe a year at most one oh okay
yeah I think I would get into the
University of Delaware and sit down with
someone in the administration there and
tell them what you're trying to do and
see if you can't figure out a way that
you get a little better overlap than
that that sounds ridiculous to me yeah
the first two years of most
undergraduate degrees are cut and paste
and you know the idea that you're the
stuff
a lot of the core stuff you took a
couple years back getting this other
degree wouldn't apply to the second
degree from the same exact University
sounds good weird amazed I really want
to do that changes that changes the
equation because it's the money you need
so what's it cost around University of
Delaware in a year about 20 grand
not tuition is it the tuition so much
actually I know I'm sorry that's for
room and board - so about thirteen okay
where are you living in that area now
yes okay
and so room and board would be you moved
back into a dorm no no I wouldn't do
that so it'd be about 13 grand for just
tuition gotcha okay all right and so
let's pretend we need two years of 13
grand that's a little over $1,000 a
month okay okay and you need two years
of that so you need $26,000 right right
okay
I'm thinking you can get this other part
worked out I'm just going to go with
that as our scenario so what you would
need to do is to create a side hustle
for the next six or eight or ten months
until you get ready to start back and
then you're gonna have to work your butt
off while you're there because you've
got you've got to you've got to make a
living and have 13,000 $1,000 a month
roughly extra okay so you have to eat
pay lights and water and pay the rent
you're not gonna have money to party and
you're going to school and working all
the time so you ain't got time to party
and and so you just you know you're
gonna work your tail end off for
approximately two and a half years and
you'll come out with a finance degree at
27 or 28 years old if that's the
direction you want to go I think that's
a wonderful thing to do but that's going
to involve a side hustle of some kind I
don't care if it's delivering pizzas or
driving uber or what but you're gonna be
making fifteen hundred two thousand
dollars a month on the side
and going to school and making enough to
live in addition to that right right you
know so that that's how you lay it out
you got to so you need to you need to
gather up more pieces of information
around this decision in order to lay out
a reasonable projection that this is
going to work out for you and the pieces
are we've got to go have a physical
meeting with someone in the
administration at the University of
Delaware and lay out exactly to the
letter what I have to do it's an exact
number of classes and they have an exact
cost to them over an exact period of
time then you lay that down on a
timeline and you say okay that's my
expenses now that and so where what does
my revenue needs well what's my minimum
budget to eat keep the lights on have
rent with a roommate or whatever I got
to do are gonna move back in with my
parents for a short period time whatever
you can do to have the minimum existence
and then I need the tuition and the
books above that during that exact
period of time that it takes to execute
this plan and that will tell you but
ruff roughly I think we've laid it out
here
I mean it's we know it's 13,000 a year
and you know you gotta lay out your
existence what that takes but you know
you don't need much of an existence you
just need to exist because we're paying
a price so that the 37 year old you
really likes the decision that the 25
year old made and you know you want the
40 year old you to like the 25 year old
you and the decisions that you made
because right now the 25 year old you
doesn't like the 18 year old you and the
decisions he made on his education
that's what you said and so we want to
reverse that trend and the way we do
that is we lay out a very detailed game
plan because no one wins at anything by
accident and the more detail you felt
that you lay out here the better you're
going to be at Finance for one thing but
the higher the likelihood is that you
graduate successfully with
no doubt and that you graduate and that
you eat and you don't get evicted during
that time so you lay out the exact plan
and then you execute the plan let's put
a bow on this thing